sauf à nous
il est le roi du style le prince des
tendances celui qui fait et défait les
modes monsieur rails
sa vie est un conte de films issus d'un
quartier populaire c'est alors qu'il
joue au basket qu'un riche homme
d'affaires repère son potentiel cool à 8
ans seulement il se lance dans la
musique et signe un tube mondial
rien ne l'arrête touche à tout de génie
colin branchouille est un danseur de
breakdance hors pair mais aussi un dj et
un street artiste les plus grandes
marques se l'arrachent son mentor décide
alors de traduire son nom en anglais
colin branche mur devient monsieur hype
un mouvement est né donc là sur le
prochain candidat on est donc sur un
danseur et pourquoi tu vas être hype
parce que c'est cool
bah écoute si tu es hype ça maintenant
[Musique]
le spécialiste des réseaux sociaux
ok coucou du coup moi c'est minable et
je suis influencé ce depuis trois ans
voilà j'ai sept cent mille abonnés sur
instagram 1 million sur tictoc ce que le
genre je peux manger par exemple une
glace à côté de notre dame un peu montré
mon lifestyle c'est hyper sympa mon
lifestyle et du mensonge
ouais des très jeunes a souvent ils sont
mineurs mais c'est pas grave ça te fait
rire ah ouais quand même
puis après je me suis mise at work et
alors là je vous explique pas vous voyez
ça bouge tout seul but c'est cool non
pas hype
non non pas
et c'est une comédienne vous venez tout
d'abord 80,2 jouer quelque chose
d'intense quelque chose de vos quartiers
qui qui qui respire et transpire la rue
j'ai pas finir femme de ménage comme toi
maman hockey ou ouais c'est mauvais très
beau vin là on n'y croit pas un instant
avec hype au revoir je m'appelle cécile
de l'afo lignières j'ai réalisé un film
en côte d'ivoire sur la précarité
sociale dans les quartiers populaires
d'abidjan d'où viens-tu inde et
versailles ah oui oui alors moi je suis
à ismaël fofana je suis né en côte
d'ivoire donc je fais du cinéma social
ok j'ai fait pas mal de reportages sur
des quartiers abobo
j'ai besoin que ce soit des gens de chez
nous qui parlons de ce à quoi ça me
touche c'est un peu ma vie quoi bein
merci monsieur jour touché à la main à
montreuil en face du foyer
il a un truc hype
on sait pas d uruguay mais andré mon
vrai truc c'est je sais chanter bien
chanter moi votre partition je t'ai dit
d'arrêter de vendre ne m'a pas écouté te
voilà enfermé et mon coeur est sous
scellé et va souffrir ailleurs dégage
c'est pas ben alors
dj black spirit y jouer au hainaut genk
s'est cherché à jouer au master i want
my money express marcel à sa place vous
exact producteurs de zouk love c'est pas
m
[Musique]
c'est une comédienne qui les casse cou
sous la halle j'adore j'adore alors vous
venez d'où 93 aïe aïe aïe à une maîtrise
du langage peut-être gitane est ce qu
ai-je technique et tara si tu continues
à me parler comme ça cela cette violence
est violent ce fonds est ce que vous
vous battez à manu mais justement
chaussée dans la gueule frère au ça dort
6 de tête
[Musique]
ben je suis gay au mot homosexuel
ok ok super la presse est la preuve qui
nous intéresse après lgbt
oui arc en ciel et les couleurs ça va je
suis hype et non mais c'est pas
suffisant il faut quelque chose il ya la
l1 ne brille que dit voilà c'est pas du
tout c'est dégueulasse
ah la la puis cette chemise allez c'est
cela
candidat suivant donc on est sur un
artiste j'ai pas aussi pas un trou
sculpteur un pain
je n'aime pas trop parler de ce que je
fais je me suis pas mal inspiré de 2,2
ce que font mes mes parents ils font
quoi au port ils sont joaillier ses
quartiers au bafa le dire tout de suite
vous êtes le fils quartier bavouzet
tarifs et pourquoi vous habiller comme
un clochard comme ça il faut pas nous
faire perdre notre temps messieurs c'est
sérieux cette histoire de hype et c'est
très sérieux
dans mon fait qu'il fallait que je te
parle parce que je réalise aussi
non vraiment j'ai fait un film
documentaire encore sur quoi j'ai pris
un van giang dans mon quartier les
candidats prêts à tout pour intégrer le
cercle très fermé de la hype ne sont pas
près de disparaître
du travail en perspective pour monsieur
hype même si l'authenticité et la
sincérité résisteront toujours à son
jugement qui te pend pourquoi tu aimes
mes parents mes parents ses rolex et une
accroche à l'été
[Musique]